but you did mention um
disease and covenant and you've been
doing some very interesting stuff from a
mathematical but also software
engineering angle
of coming up with ideas it's back to the
i can
i see a problem i think i can help uh
so you stepped into this world can you
tell me about
your work there under the flag of novid
and both the the software and the
technical details of how the thing works
sure sure so first i want to make sure
that i say this is actually team effort
i happen to be the one speaking but
there's no way this would exist without
an incredible team of people who inspire
me every day to
work on this but i'll speak on behalf of
them so
the idea was indeed that we stepped
forward
in march of last year when the world
started to become
our part of the world started to become
our part meaning the united states
started to become paralyzed by coven the
shutdown started to happen
and at that time it started as a figment
of an idea which was
network theory which is the area of math
that i work in
could potentially be combined with
smartphones and some kind of
health information anonymized exactly
how
we didn't know yet we tried to
crystallize it and many months into this
work we
ended up accidentally discovering a new
way to control diseases
which is now what is the main impetus of
all of this work is to take this idea
and polish it and hopefully have it be
useful not only now
but for future pandemics the idea is
really simple to describe um
actually my main thing in the world is i
come up with obvious observations
that's that's so i'll explain it now
einstein did the same thing
and he wrote a few short papers so
but but so uh the idea is like this if i
if we describe
how usually people control disease
for a lot of history it was that you'd
find out
who was sick you'd find out who they
have been around
and you try to remove all of those
people from society against their will
yes now that's the problem the against
the will part
gives you the wrong kind of a feedback
loop which makes it hard to control the
disease
because then the people you're trying to
control keep getting other people sick
you can see already i'm thinking and
talking about this feedback loops this
is actually related to something you
said earlier
about even like how skyscrapers stay in
the air uh the whole point is
control theory you actually want to or
even how an airplane stays
you need to have control loops which are
feedbacking in the right way
and what we observed was that the
feedback control loop for
controlling disease by asking people to
be removed from society against their
will
was not working it was running against
human incentives and you suddenly are
trying to control seven
billion eight billion people in ways
that they don't individually want
to necessarily do so here's the idea uh
and this is inspired by the fact that at
the core of our team were user
experience designers that's actually
in fact the first thing i knew we needed
when we started was to bring user
experience
at the core okay but so um
the idea was suppose there was a penta
suppose hypothetically
there was a pandemic what would you
want you would want a way to be able to
live your life as much as possible
and avoid getting sick can we make an
app to help
you avoid getting sick notice how i've
just articulated the problem
it is not can we make an app so that
after you are around somebody who's sick
you can be removed from society it's can
we make an app so that
you can avoid getting sick that would
run a positive feed
however i don't know if i want to call
it positive or negative but they would
run a good feedback loop yes
okay so then how would you do this the
only problem is that
you don't know who's sick because
especially with this disease
if i see somebody who looks perfectly
healthy the disease spreads two days
before you have any symptoms
and so it's actually not possible that's
where the network theory comes in
you caught it from someone what if
we changed the paradigm and we said
whenever there's a sickness
tell everybody how many physical
relationships
separate them from the sickness that is
the trivial idea we added
the trivial idea was the distance
between you and a disease
is not measured in feet or seconds
it's measured in terms of how many close
physical relationships
separate you like these six degrees of
separation like linkedin
simple idea what if we told everyone
that it turns out that actually
unlocks some interesting behavioral
feedback loops
which for example let me let me now jump
to a non-covered example to show why
this
maybe could be useful actually we think
it could be quite useful
imagine there was ebola or some
hemorrhagic fever
imagine it spread through contact
through the air in fact pretend
pretend um that's a
that's a disastrous disease it has high
fatality rate
and uh as you die you're bleeding out of
every orifice okay
so yeah not pleasant not pleasant so the
question is
suppose that such a disease broke
who would want to install an app that
would tell them how many relationships
away from them
this disease had struck like a lot of
people a lot of people in fact
almost i don't want to say almost
everyone that's a very strong statement
but a very large number of people
that's fascinating framing like the the
more deadly and transmissible the
disease
the the stronger the incentive to
install it
in a positive sense the in in the good
feedback loop sense that's a really good
example it's a really good way to frame
it because
with covid it was not as deadly
as uh as potential uh pandemics could
have been viruses could have been so
it's sometimes muddled with how we think
about it but yeah this is a really good
framing if if the virus was a lot more
deadly uh you want to create a system
that has a set of incentives that uh
it it quickly expresses a population
where everybody is using it
and it's contributing in a positive way
to the system
exactly and actually that point you just
made i don't take credit for that
observation there was another person i
talked to who pointed out that
it's very interesting that this feedback
loop is even more effective
when the disease is worse and that's
actually
not a bad characteristic to have in your
feedback loop if you're trying to help
civilization keep running yeah it's a
really
it's in this dynamic like people
figure out they dynamically figure out
how bad the disease is
the more it spreads and the deadlier it
is as the people observe it as long as
the spread of information
like uh semantic information natural
language information
is closely aligned with the reality of
the disease which is a whole nother
conversation right
we that's we might maybe we'll chat
about that how we
sort of make sure there's not
misinformation while there's accurate
information but
that aside okay so this is a really nice
property
right and and just going on on that
actually just talking more about what
that could do and why we're so excited
about it
it's that not only would people want to
install it
what would they do if you start to see
that this disease is getting closer and
closer
we surveyed informally people but they
said as we saw it getting closer
we would hide we would try to not have
contacts but now you notice what this
has just achieved
the whole goal on on this whole exercise
was
you got the people who might be sick and
you got everyone else
set a and set b set a is the people who
might be sick that b is everyone else
and for the entirety of the past uh
contact tracing approaches
you try to get set a to do things that
might not be
to their liking or their will because
that's removing them from society
yes we found out that there's two ways
to separate set a from set b
you can also let the people at set b at
the fringe of set a
attempt to remove themselves from this
interface it's just it's the symmetry of
a and b separation
everyone was looking at a we look at b
and suddenly b
is in their incentive to do so beautiful
so there's a virus that jumps from human
to human so there's a network
sometimes called graph of
the spread of a virus it hops from
person to person to person to person
and each one of us individuals are
sitting
or plop plopped into that network we
have
close friends and relations and so on
it's kind of fascinating to actually
think about this network and we can
maybe talk about the shapes of this kind
of network
because i was trying to think exactly
this like how many people do i
was some kind of an introvert not kind
of i'm very much an introvert
but so can i be explicit about the kind
of people i
meet in regular life say when it was
completely opened up there's no pandemic
there is a kind of network of cl and
there's maybe
um in the graph theoretic sense there's
some weights
or something about how
close that relationship is in terms of
the frequency visits
the duration of visits and all those
kinds of things so you're saying
we might want to be to create
uh on top of that network a spread of
information
to let you know as the virus travels
through this network how close is it
getting to you
and the number of hops away it is on
that network
is really powerful information that
creates a positive
feedback loop where you can act
essentially anonymously uh and
on your own like nobody's telling you
what to do
which is really important is
decentralized
and uh and and not yeah whatever the
opposite of authoritarian is
but you get to sort of the american way
you get to choose to do it yourself you
have the freedom to do it
yourself and you're incentivized to do
it and you're most likely going to do it
to
to uh to protect yourself against um
gets you getting the disease as the the
closer it gets to you based on the
information that you have
but uh can you maybe elaborate uh first
of all
brilliant uh whenever i saw the thing
you're working on
uh so forget for covid this is of course
really relevant for covid but it's also
probably relevant for future diseases as
well so this uh
that was the thing i'm nervous about
it's like if this whole if our society
shut down because of covid like
what the heck is gonna happen when
there's a much deadlier disease
like this this is disappointing the
whole time
2020 the whole time i'm just sitting
like this like
is the incompetence of everybody except
the people developing vaccines uh the
biologists are the only ones that got
their stuff together
but in terms of institutions and all
that kind of stuff oh it's just been
it's just been terrible but this is
exactly the power of information
and the power of information that
doesn't limit personal freedom
so your idea is brilliant okay
mathematically can you maybe elaborate
what are we talking about like how do
you actually make that work
what's involved sure first i'm going to
reply to something you said about
the freedom inside this because actually
that was the idea the idea is
this is game theory right and
effectively what we did is
analogous to free market
economy as opposed to central planning
yeah if you just
line up the set of incentives correctly
so that people
have in their purely selfish behavior
are contributing to the optimization of
the global function
yes that's it and the the point of what
we do i guess in mathematics is we try
to
explore the search space to go and find
out as many possibilities as there are
and in this case it's an apply in this
case it's an applied search space that's
why the
inputs from design user experience
design and actual people are important
but you asked about um i guess the tech
the mathematical or the technical things
underpinning it
so i think the first thing i'll say is
we wanted to make this thing
not require your personal information
and so in order to do that
what gave me the confidence to i guess
lead our team to run at the beginning
is we saw that this could be done
without using gps information
so technically what's going on is if two
smartphones it's a smartphone app if two
smartphones have this thing installed
they just communicate with each other by
bluetooth
to go and find out how far they can they
can detect nearby things by bluetooth
and then they can find out that these
two phones were approximately such and
such distance apart
and that kind of relative proximity
information is enough to construct
this big network okay so the physical
network
is constructed based on proximity that's
through bluetooth and you don't have to
specify
your exact location it's the proximity
i'm not using the pythagorean theorem
basically i mean if i just knew the gps
coordinates we could use the pythagorean
theorem too sorry that's just how i call
it distance formula whatever you want to
call it
[Laughter]
uh yeah so we're not doing the old by
targaryen uh
based violation of privacy okay
[Laughter]
but so is that
is that enough to form to give you
enough information about
physical connection to another human
being
is there a time element there is there
so okay
that sounds like a really strong like
low-hanging fruit
like if you have that you could probably
go really really far
my natural question is is there extra
information you can add on top of that
like the duration
of the physical proximity uh so first of
all we actually do
estimate the duration but the way we
estimate the duration
is like how a movie is filmed in the
sense that every so often every few
minutes
we check what's nearby it's it's like
how a movie is filmed you take lots of
snapshots
yes so there's no way in a battery
efficient way
to really keep track of that proximity
however fortunately we're using
probability the fact is
the paradigm that we're using is it's
not super important
if you run into that person only for 10
minutes at the grocery store
if that's a stranger that you run into
10 minutes in this grocery store
that's not going to be relevant for our
paradigm because our paradigm is not
telling you who were you around before
and might therefore
have gotten infected by already ours is
about predicting the future we changed
from
i mean the standard paradigm was what
already happened quick damage control
ourselves predict the future if you run
into that person once in the grocery
store today and never see them again
it's irrelevant for predicting the
future and therefore
for ours what really matters is the many
hours
around the other person at which point
if you're scanning every five to eight
minutes
that's going to come out in the profit
like statistically speaking it's going
to come out as a strong relationship
and a person in the grocery store is
going to wash out
that's not an important physical
relationship i mean this is brilliant
what how difficult is it to make work so
you said
one there's a mathematical component
that we just kind of talked about
and then there's the user experience
component so
how difficult is it to go just like you
built the video game
alien attack from zero to
to completion what's involved how
difficult is it
so i'm going to answer that question in
terms of building the product
but then i'm also going to acknowledge
that just having an
app doesn't make it useful because the
the
that's actually maybe the easy part if
you know what i mean
there's like all of this stuff about
rollout adoption and awareness but let's
focus on the app part first so that's
again why is that
the team is incredible so we have a
bunch of people
who let's just say that the technology
that we use to make it
is not the standard way you make an app
if you think about a standard
ios app or android app those are a user
interface
that contacts a web server and sends
some information back and forth
we're doing some stuff that has to hook
into the operating system of saying
let's go use bluetooth for something it
wasn't really meant for
right so there's that part and by the
way what is the app called
oh it's called novid covered with an ad
very nice so you have to hook into
bluetooth you're saying you have to do
that
um beyond the permissions that are
like at the very surface level provided
on the phone
well i don't want to call them
permissions i just want to say that's
not what you usually do with bluetooth
gotcha
usually with bluetooth you say do i have
headphones nearby
yes okay i'm done you don't go and say
do i have headphones nearby
or do i have another phone nearby which
is doing something and then keep asking
that simply keep asking the question
right so this is actually not easy and i
mean there were some parts of it
which actually a lot of people had tried
unsuccessfully
um actually it's it's known that for
example the uk was trying to do
something
uh similar and the problem they ran into
was when you program things on ios
ios is very good at making it hard to do
things in the background
and so there was quite a lot of effort
required to go and make this thing work
so the whole point this thing would run
in the background and
ios i mean most
android probably as well right but yeah
ios certainly makes it difficult for
something to run in the background
especially when it's to eating up your
battery right
ah well we wanted to make sure we didn't
eat up the battery so that one we can we
actually are very proud of the fact that
ours uses very little battery
uh actually even if compared to apple's
own system
so beautiful so what else is required to
make this thing work
right so the the key was that you had to
do significant amount of work on the
actual mobile app development
which fortunately the team that we
brought was this kind of general
thinkers where we would dig in deep into
the operating system documentation and
the api libraries
so we got that working but there's
another angle which is you also need the
servers to be able to compute fast
enough
which is tying back to this old school
computer programming competitions and
math olympiads
in fact our team that was working on the
algorithm and back-end side
included several people who had been in
these
competitions from before which i happen
to know because i i do
coach the team for the math yes and so
we were able to bring people in
to build servers a server infrastructure
in
c plus actually so that we could support
significant numbers of people
without needing tons of surface is there
some distributed algorithms
working here or you basically have to
keep
in in the same place the entire graph as
it builds because
especially the more more people use it
the bigger the bigger the graph gets
i mean this is very difficult uh scaling
problem right
ah so that's actually why uh this
computer algorithm competition stuff was
handy
it's because there are only about
seven to eight giga people in the world
yeah
that's not that many so if you can make
your algorithms linear time or almost
linear time
a computer operates in gigahertz yeah i
only need to do one run
one one recalculation every hour in
terms of telling people how far away
these dangers are
yes so i suddenly have 3 600 seconds
and my cpu cores are running in
gigahertz
and at most they're eight giga people
well you're skipping over the fact that
uh there's n
squared potential connections between
people
so how do you get around the fact that
uh
you know that we you know the potential
set of relationship any one of us could
have
8 billion so it's 8 billion times
squared
that's you that's potential amount of
data you have to be storing
and computing over and constantly
updating so the way we dealt with that
is we actually expect that the typical
network
is very sparse the the technical term
sparse would mean that the
average degree or the average number of
connections that a person has
is going to be at most like 100 strong
connections that you care about
if you if you think of it almost in
terms of the heavy hitters actually
in most people's lives 100 if we just
kept track of their top 100
interactions that's probably most of the
signal
yeah yeah i i i'm saddened to think
that i might not be even in a double
digits but oh
i i was intentionally giving a crazy
number to account for college students
you call oh those are the who you call
the heavy hitters the people who are
like the social butterflies
yeah yeah yeah i need to uh um i'd love
to know that information about myself by
the way the
that i do do you uh expose the graph
like how many like about yourself how
many connections you have
we do expose to each person how many
direct connections they have that's
great but for privacy purposes
we don't tell anybody who their
connections like how their connections
are interconnected
yes gotcha but at the same time we do
expose also to everyone an interesting
chart that says
here's how many people you have that
you're connected to directly
here's how many at distance two meaning
via people and then here's how many at
distance three
and the reason we do that is that
actually ends up being a dynamic that
also boosts adoption it drives another
feedback loop
the reason is because we saw actually
when we deployed this in some
universities
that when people see on their app that
they are
indirectly connected to hundreds or
thousands of other people
they get excited and they tell other
people hey let's download this app yeah
but you know we also saw in those
examples especially looking at the
screenshots people gave
that is hit as soon as the typical
person
has two or three other direct
connections on the system
because that means that our app has
reached a virality are not
of two to three the key is we were
making a viral app to fight a virus
spreading on the same network that the
virus spreads on
so you're trying to out virus the virus
that's right
that's exactly right okay great what
have you learned
from this whole experience in terms of
um
let's say for covid but for future
pandemics as well
is it possible to use the power
information here of networked
information
as the virus spreads and travels in
order to basically keep the society open
is it possible for for people to protect
themselves with this information
or do you still have to have most like
in this overarching policy of everybody
should stay at home
all that kind of thing we are trying to
answer that question right now so
the answer is we don't know yet but
that's actually why we're very happy
that
now the idea has started to become
become more widely known
and we're already starting to
collaborate with uh epidemiologists
again i'm just a mathematician right and
a mathematician should not be the person
who is telling everybody
this will definitely work but because of
the potential power
of this approach especially the
potential power of this being an
end game for kovid we have gotten the
interest of
real researchers and we're now working
together
to try to actually understand the answer
to that question because you see
there's a theory so what i can share is
the mathematics of
here's why there's some hope that this
would work yeah and that's because
i'm talking about end game now end game
means you have very few cases
but everywhere we're always thinking
once there's few cases then does that
mean we now open up
once you open up in the past then the
cases go up again
until you have to lock down again yeah
and now when we talk about the dynamic
process
that makes it's guaranteeing you always
have cases until you have the great
vaccines which is you know
we both got vaccinated this is this is
good uh but at the same time why i'm
thinking this is still important is
because we know that
many vaccine makers have said they're
preparing for the next dose next year
and if we have a perpetual thing where
you just always need a new vaccine every
year
it could actually be beneficial to make
sure we have as many other techniques as
possible
for parts of the world that can't afford
for example
that kind of distribution yeah so
actually no matter no matter how deadly
the virus is
no matter how many things whether you
have a vaccine or not
it's still useful to be having this
information yes because
to stay home or not depending on how
risky like i'm a big fan just like you
said of uh having the freedom
for you to decide how risk-averse you
want to be right
and depending on your own conditions but
also on the state of like what you
just how dangerously you like to live so
i think that actually makes a lot of
sense and i also think that
um since we're when we when you think of
disease spreading
it spreads in aggregate in the sense
that
uh if there are some people who maybe
are more
risk tolerant because of other things in
their life well there might also be
other people who are
less risk tolerance and then those
people decide to
isolate but what matters is in the
aggregate that this are not of the
infection
uh spreading drops below one and so the
key is if you if you can empower people
with that power to make that decision
you might actually still be able to
drive that are not down below one
yeah and also this is me talking i
yes people get a little bit nervous i
think
with the information somehow mapping to
privacy violation but
i first of all in the approach you're
describing
that's respecting anonymity
but i would love to have information
from the very beginning
from march and april of last year
almost like a map of like
where it's risky and where it's not
to go and not map based on sort of the
exact location of people but where
people usually hang out kind of thing
just maybe not necessarily about actual
location but just maybe activities
like just to have information about what
is
what is good to do or not you know in
terms of like safety
is it okay to run outside and not is it
okay to go to a restaurant or not
i just feel like we're operating the
blind and then what you had
is a very imperfect uh signal which is
like basically politicians
desperately trying to make statements
about what is safe and not they don't
know what the heck they're doing
they have a bunch of smart scientists
telling them stuff and the scientists
themselves
also very important don't always know
what they're doing
epidemiology is not
is as much an art as a science you're
desperately trying to predict the future
which nobody can do
and then you're trying to speak with
some level of authority
i mean if i were to criticize scientists
they spoke with too much authority it's
okay to say i'm not sure
but then they think like if i say i'm
not sure
then there's going to be a distrust what
they realize is when you're wrong and
you say i'm sure
it's going to lead to more distrust so
this is imperfect like
just chaotic messy system of people
trying to figure out with very little
information
and what you're proposing is just a huge
amount of information
and information is power is there um
challenges with adoption that you see in
the future
here so there's uh maybe we could speak
to there's approaches i guess from
google
there's different people that have tried
similar kind of ideas
not in you you have a quite a novel idea
actually uh but
speaking the umbrella idea of contact
tracing
is is there is there something you can
comment about
why their approaches haven't been fully
adopted uh is there challenges there is
there
is there reasons why novid might be a
better idea moving forward
in general just about adoption yeah so
first of all i want to say i always have
respect for the
methods that other people use and so
it's good to see that other people have
been trying
but what we have noticed is that the
difference between
our value proposition to the user and
the value proposition to the user
delivered by everything that was made
before
is that unfortunately the action of
installing a standard contact tracing
app
will then tell you after you have
already been exposed to the disease
so that you can protect other people
from you and what that does
to your own direct probability of
getting sick if you think about it
suppose you were making the decision
should i or should i not install one of
those apps
yeah what does that do to your own
probability of getting sick
it's close to zero this is uh the sad
thing you're um
you're speaking to not sad i suppose
it's the way of the world is
the only incentive there is to just help
other people i suppose but
a much stronger incentive is is anything
that allows you to help yourself
yes so what i'm saying is that uh let's
just say free market capitalism was not
based on altruism i think it's based on
if you make a system of incentives so
that everybody trying to maximize their
own situation
somehow contributes to the whole that's
a game's theoretic solution to a very
hard problem
and so this is actually basically
mechanism design like we've basically
come up with a different mechanism
different set of incentives which
incentivizes the adoption
because actually whenever we've been
rolling it out usually the first
question we ask
people like say in the university is do
you know what nova does
and most of them have read about the
other apps and they say oh no it will
tell you after you've been around
someone so you can quarantine
and we have to explain to them actually
novid never wants to ask you to
quarantine
yeah that's not the principle our
principle isn't based on that at all
we just want to let you know if
something is coming close
so that you can protect yourself if you
want yeah if you want if you want
and then the quarantine is like yes in
that case if you're quarantining
it's because you're shutting the door
from the inside it makes
sense yes exactly exactly i mean this is
brilliant but so what
do you think the future looks like for
future pandemics what's your plan
with novid what's your plan with these
set of ideas i am
actually still an academic and a
researcher so the biggest work i'm
working on right now
is to try to build as many
collaborations with other public health
researchers
at other universities to actually work
on
pilot deployments together in various
places that's the goal
that's actually ongoing work right now
and so for example if anyone's watching
this and you happen to be a public
health researcher
and you want to be involved in something
like this i'm just going to say i'm
still incentive thinking
there's something in it for the
researchers too this could open up an
entire new way of controlling disease
that's my hope
i mean it might actually be true and
people who are involved
in figuring out how to make this work
well it could actually be good for their
careers too
i i always have to think like if a
researcher was getting involved what are
they getting out of it
oh so you mean like uh from a research
perspective you can um
like publications and sets of ideas
about how to from a sort of uh
uh network theory perspective understand
how we control the spread of a pandemic
yes and what i'm doing right now is this
is basically interdisciplinary research
where maybe our side is bringing the
technology and the network theory
and the missing parts are epidemiology
and public health expertise
and if the two things start to join also
because everywhere that you deploy
let's just say that the world is
different in the philippines as it is in
the united states
and just the natures of the of the
locality would mean that
someone like me should not be trying to
figure out how to do that but if we can
work with the researchers who are based
there
now suddenly we might come up with a
solution that will help scale in parts
of the world
where they aren't all getting the
moderna and pfizer vaccines which cost
like 20 of pop in the u.s so if they
want to participate
who did they reach out to oh that would
just be us i mean the novid.org website
has
nova.org it has it has a feedback reach
out form
and actually we are i mean again this is
the dna of being a researcher
i am actually very excited by the idea
that this could
contribute knowledge that will outlast
all of our generations
like all of our lifetimes there you go
reach out
to novanova.org uh what about individual
people
should they install the app and try it
out or is this really geographically
restricted
oh yeah i didn't come on here to tell
everyone to install the app i did not
come to tell everyone to install the app
because it
works best if your local health
authority is working with us
gotcha there's a reason it's because
this is back to the game theory
if anyone could just say i'm positive
the high school senior prank would be to
say that
we have a massive outbreak on finals
week let's not have final exams
so the way that our system works it
actually borrows some ideas not
borrowers we came up with them
independently but this idea is similar
to what
google and apple do which is that if the
local health authority is working with
this
they can for everyone who's positive
gives them a passcode that expires in a
short time
so for ours if you're on the app and
saying i'm positive you can either just
say that
and that's called unverified or you can
enter in one of these codes that you got
from the local health authority
so basically for anyone who's watching
this it's not that you should just go
and download it unless you want to go
and look at it
that's cool but if you on the other hand
if you happen to know anyone at the
local health authority which is trying
to figure out how to handle
kovid well then i mean we'd be very
happy to also work with you
guys so the the verified there is really
important because you're
you're maintaining anonymity and because
of that you have to have some source of
verification
in order to make sure that it's not
possible to manipulate
because uh it's it's ultimately about
trust and information and so it could be
um verification is really important
there so basically individual people
should um
ask their local health authorities to
just to sign up to contact you
i hope this spreads i hope this spreads
uh for future pandemics because i'm
really
i'm it's the amount the millions of
people
who are hurt by this i think
our response to the virus economically
speaking the
number of people who lost their dream
lost their jobs
but also lost their dream entrepreneurs
you know jobs often give meaning
there's people who financially and
psychologically are suffering because of
our i'll say incompetent response to the
virus
uh across the world but certainly the
united states that should be the beacon
of uh entrepreneurial hope for the world
so
uh i hope that uh
we'll be able to respond to these kinds
of events much better in the future and
this is exactly the right kind of idea
and now is the time to do the investment
you